wir haben nur mit einer keule
funktechnik was ist ich muss noch mal
okay ist besser okay wir haben diesen
tonprobleme deshalb heute -interview nur
mit einer keule technik die nicht
begeistert so ist es manchmal mit
technik erst mal herzlich willkommen
glasperlenspiel wie ist die lage alles
auf kurs also schönen köln und freuen
uns sehr dass das geklappt hat und aber
uns ist also jetzt steht alles in
statischer für die zweite platte und es
gibt bald wieder los wir sind ja
zusammen gekommen weil wir mitmachen
oder ehren mitmachen aber die sagen
mitmachen so die anderen aber wir
unterstützen einen wettbewerb 361 grad
respekt man kann videos einreichen und
zwar zum thema gegen mobbing für
toleranz wie seid ihr dazu gekommen wie
die jungfrau zum kinde oder ist das
etwas im thema wo er sagt da haben wir
was zu sagen es war auf jeden fall ganz
nützlich also wir haben auf unserer
aktuellen platte einen song geschrieben
und dieser song den hat youtube zu
wirklichen hände bekommen und haben den
gehört und haben das hat einfach sehr
gut gepasst zu diesem thema und der song
heißt lasst uns was bewegen und die sind
auf uns zugekommen habe gefragt ob uns
das prinzipiell vorstellen könnten eben
eine zusammenarbeit
ob wir die kampagne kennen und ich
kannte sich tatsächlich und ich habe
auch die jahre davor die bands auch
verfolgt die das schon mitgemacht haben
und für uns ist das thema auch einfach
sehr wichtig doch warum wir auch einen
song darüber geschrieben haben und dann
war das eigentlich auch gleich klar das
passt perfekt wir sind dabei also wenn
man sowas unterstützen kann ist
natürlich immer eine super sache
thema ist für euch wichtig mobbing ist
ja oft ein thema auch an der schule ihr
seid ja noch quasi gerade aus der schule
ist ein bisschen übertrieben aber jetzt
wann habt ihr gemacht ich 2008 nicht
bäumchen wechsel dich mach mit dem mikro
wie war das bei euch an der schule ist
mobbing da damals schon sage ich wo
facebook ja nicht so ein thema war wo
heute ja auch sehr viel mobbing
passiert war das damals ähnlich oder was
war damals anders als heute
also ich kann da so ein bisschen aus
eigener erfahrung sprechen dass ich war
deinem alter also achte neunte klasse
was sowieso glaube ich sehr schwierig
ist weil man einem alter ist ja jeder so
sich erstmal selber finden muss und
sagen was okay das sind meine meine
standpunkte und soundso sicherheit
einfach ordnen und in der schule war das
dann einfach so dass das an die jungs
irgendwie auch meinten jahres muss man
mal ein thema suchen dem wir dann ärgern
können den wir irgendwie ein bisschen
schikanieren können und bei mir war das
der noch teilweise so dass ich wirklich
auch anfangs gleich mehr in die schule
wollt oder gesagt habe ich hab jetzt
echt angst in die schule zu gehen weil
wenn man die klasse kommt und man wird
angeschaut und man weiß ganz genau jetzt
kommt gleich wieder ein blöder kommentar
und deswegen was uns auch besonders
wichtig zu sagen weil oder auch mir weil
ich gesagt hab ich habe das selber
erlebt und es ist sehr wichtig dass man
unterstützung von anderen bekommt und
dass ich auch oft lehrer einschalten das
habe ich auch gesehen dass es nicht so
ist also dass lehrer und mitschüler auch
oft weg gucken und sagen ja ich will
mich das nicht gegen auflehnen weil
sonst bekomme ich auch noch den ärger
und das finde ich eben ganz wichtig dass
man den schülern auch vielleicht das
gefühl gibt okay ich kann mich da auch
gegen auf lehnen und sagen ich muss dir
mit oder ich kann dem helfen und den
schülern quasi so mit dieser aktion auch
mut machen sich da so ein bisschen
dagegen aufzulehnen
was hat aber was halt wirklich extremen
heutigen zeit ist das man einfach durch
die neuen medien wie facebook und
twitter und was alles gibt es einfach so
viel schneller so viel krass viel mehr
menschen erreicht also man wenn man
jetzt irgendwie mal auf dem kieker hatte
und das war dann irgendwie vielleicht
auch klassen intern bezogen und das gab
es auch wahrscheinlich schon vor 50
jahren aber ihr heute ist es so dann
wird irgendwann ins internet gepostet
was da halt auf ewig drin stehen wird
und das kriegen dann ein paar tausend
menschen auf einmal zu lesen auf einmal
am nächsten tag weiß die ganze schule
und das ist halt dieses extrem was
glaube ich hart ist einfach auch weil es
einfach viel breiter kommuniziert wird
und dass es da sollte man auf jeden fall
schon was
tun aber auch sagen das ist nicht cool
darauf sollte man ansetzen was ja dieses
jahr auch was in kanada zum traurigen
fall geführt hat mädchen das sich dann
letztlich umgebracht hat aufgrund des
mobbings letztes video gab es auf
youtube zu sehen
was sind denn eure erfahrung was kann
man dagegen tun
ich denke dass es oft schwierig ist aber
wie schon gesagt ich glaube das ist
wichtig dass lehrer dann noch ein
bisschen mehr gucken also es gibt schon
noch lehrer die sich darum kümmern aber
es ist oft so dass das natürlich auch
schwer ist es zu entdecken so weil eine
klasse hat 30 schüler und dann die auf
jeden einzelnen guckt man ja auch nicht
aber man kriegt es ja auch nicht mit
weiß so hintenrum ist und niemand sagt
was aber genau deswegen finde ich auch
wichtig dass man dass man den schülern
sagt wie wichtig es ist und den stand
das gefühl gibt dass man dass man auch
helfen kann und dass man auch helfen
will und möchte dass es wichtig ist auch
für die andere person oder für die
gemobbte person und deswegen finde ich
ganz gut dass man dass man sagt so
machen wir den schülern eben mutig dann
einzuschalten und mitzuwirken und
dagegen zu wirken
ja und also da setzt auch dieser report
reimann als ich gerade 361 grad richtig
an und einfach ein bewusstsein zu
schaffen dafür dass es nicht cool aus
und das ich glaube wenn du schon
wirklich dann wenn da einfach sehr viele
leute hervor gehen und sagen
sechs mal wenn ich mobbingopfer so oder
so dann sage ich hey das ist nicht gut
auf und das ist glaube ich schon der
schritt der wichtig ist einfach zu sagen
hey das einfach ein bewusstsein zu
schaffen zu sagen das ist nicht cool
ich muss mich ja auch mal irgendwie
dagegen auflehnen oder was ich jetzt
auch gehört habe was natürlich sehr gut
ist dass man vielleicht einmal in der
woche mit mit dem lehrer zusammen solche
stunden macht also ich es wird
wahrscheinlich auch oft was bringen
denke ich wenn man sagt man setzt sich
zusammen und man redet jetzt wie freunde
miteinander also die komplette klasse
jeder meldet sich oder oder man setzt
sich zusammen irgendwie gar nicht so die
schulische normal situationen sondern
man setzt sich irgendwie zusammen und
sagt eine stunde nehmen wir uns jetzt
zeit und reden über über das was man
persönlich denkt weil ich denke das geht
oft verloren so in der schule also
natürlich ist mit dem ganzen schulstoff
und so das ist natürlich schwierig dann
immer eine stunde noch mehr zu finden
denn der mann vielleicht auch über die
über die probleme in der klasse oder
welche organisatorische probleme reden
kann aber ich denke es würde vielleicht
auch schon helfen wenn man dann so der
lehrer noch mit einbezieht und sagt okay
hier sind dann probleme da wie geht ihr
damit um weil das musikbusiness ist ja
auch nicht was ein business was durch
extrem große freundschaft geprägte sich
da da gibt's auch neid missgunst
vielleicht auch aus eigenem antrieb sagt
nachdem finde ich aber blöd weil der
sich so und so verhält wie geht er damit
um sagte wir reden nie darüber oder wie
geht man im musikbusiness damit um also
ich sag mal das geht ja teilweise im rap
business bis dahin dass die leute sich
in anführungszeichen bekriegen ja wie
geht ihr damit um weil ihr mögt er
sicher auch den einen oder anderen
musiker einfach dem mögt ihr nicht
wir müssen also ganz ehrlich sagen wir
hatten zum glück ist noch nicht so viele
erfahrungen mit machen müssen und ich
finde also generell ja sowieso musik ist
ja so subjektiv also ich meine es gibt
einfach künstler die gefahren ein
persönlich selber besser und es gibt
eine die gefahren haben nicht ich finde
einfach der respekt zu sagen ob mir das
gefällt oder nicht respekt vor der
leistung was er da macht einfach mit mit
diesem genre musik und das ist auch so
meine einstellungen also ich habe da gar
nicht ich würde es auch gar nicht
irgendwie behaupten aber das finde ich
irgendwie kacke oder durch wieder was an
ist gefällt mir nicht es ist aber nicht
meine musikrichtung aber er macht es
trotzdem super und ich glaube das ist
also die richtige herangehensweise wenn
wir uns einfach gerade so in den
kreativen branchen ist einfach das ist
also jeder hat da eine andere meinung
weil er natürlich auch geschmäcker
auseinander gehen und manchmal nur schon
bild und in einem raum sitzen 20
menschen und 20.10 sagen finde ich kacke
und anderen sagen finde ich gut und ich
meine das ist ja auch im endeffekt die
meinung die man selber vertritt aber ich
glaube da muss man auch dann einfach
entscheiden
wie dann auch den rapper die da wirklich
anfangen und sagen oh scheiße was du
machst und so und fangen sich da
wirklich an zu dissen das hat dann
irgendwann auch mal vielleicht die
grenze ich meine aber das gehört
vielleicht auch ein bisschen bei denen
zum image dazu zuschauer und ein
bisschen aber wie gesagt das also
glücklicherweise mussten wir damit noch
nicht viel erfahrung machen das heißt
wenn ihr jemand richtig scheiße findet
sagt ihr euch trotzdem okay das was er
macht werden wir doof aber respekt aber
trotzdem weil er hat erfolg damit er
macht sein ding ist dass die richtig ist
dass so eure einstellung
na ja also es stimmt schon ich finde man
sollte klar wenn jetzt jemand wirklich
was macht wenn man sagt das geht
überhaupt nicht da muss man sich
einschalten wird wenn er aktiv jemanden
mobbt dann finde ich da muss man sich
einfach einschalten wenn sie das weil
wir jetzt gerade vom künstlerischen
gesprochen haben dafür nicht da gibt's
ja auch diese künstlerische freiheit man
sagt okay er macht jetzt halt so was und
mir gefällt es vielleicht nicht oder ein
bestimmtes genre das mir nicht gefällt
dann würde ich jetzt niemals sagen also
das finde ich total scheiße vor
laufender kamera aber ich finde es nicht
in ordnung weil er hat genau das recht
dazu das zu tun und unter seine
künstlerische ader auszuleben und es
gibt leute die das mögen und ich würde
sowas einfach aus prinzip nicht machen
weil sowas finde ich es geht einfach
nicht in ordnung weil es hat auch seine
daseinsberechtigung alles übertragen auf
den alltag würde das halten heißen ja
respekt vor jedem menschen von dem was
er tut for all seinen eigenschaften ob
ich sag mal meistens ist mobbing bezieht
sich auf irgendwelche schwächen heißt
dass man ich sag mal eine dicke nase hat
dass man dick ist dass man vielleicht
keine ahnung kommissare hat eine dicke
brille trägt es wenn er immer die
schwächen herausgesucht von menschen und
letztlich heißt es ja wir müssen so oder
so respektvoll miteinander umgehen und
dürfen diese schwächen nicht zum anlass
nehmen jemand fertig zu machen weil er
hat ja dann woanders die stärken würde
dir das auch würde dem zustimmen
ach so sehr sehr schön sagt also finde
ich gut
ja weil das ist ja wirklich auch immer
das problem man hat man es ja auch so
oder so man mag leute nicht wie geht man
mit leuten um die man nicht mag
und da ist ja die frage trage ich das
nach außen oder trage ich nicht nach
außen und ich glaube jetzt komme ich
hier bin ich aus der frage raus und gibt
es das aber hängt damit zusammen
und ich glaube man muss es halt
letztlich für sich behalten weil der
mensch geht auch sein weg und man hat
respekt vor dem zu haben ist
ich hab das auch gemerkt habe ich auch
meine brille bekommen so in der in der
achten klasse und dann ist es natürlich
von den jungs brillenschlange hier immer
immer den hier gemacht und soll ich das
super
vielen dank also natürlich ist es so
dass man sich da nicht welchen raus und
es ist auch einfach jemanden wegen
seiner schwächen zu kritisieren und
einfach bei den schwengel bei den
stärken vielleicht ganz die zu
ignorieren und zu sagen ich mach dich
jetzt fertig war deine brille hast weil
mir das vielleicht nicht passt und weil
das gerade alle lustig finden und ich
denke dass es auch oft in dem alter ist
dass es jungs vor allem auch machen weil
sie sich dadurch stärker führen oder
irgendwelche schwächen selber
kompensieren müssen oder ich weiß es
nicht also ich habe mich das auch oft
gefragt sowieso war das so aber ich
denke das ist einfach in den
altersklassen schwieriges alter eben und
dann versuchen sich irgendwie bis hinauf
zu spielen und ich weiß nicht das ist ja
auch der punkt leute die mappen haben
wir eigentlich die größte schwäche
das ist nämlich nötig haben andere leute
fertig zu machen das ist ja eine riesen
schwäche die man hat da muss man ja
irgendein problem mit seinem
selbstbewusstsein haben wenn man auf
andere leute einschlägt ich glaube so
was muss man auch mal nach außen tragen
und sagen hier die mobber sind ja
eigentlich die opfer in
anführungszeichen weil es ist nötig an
super so ihr seid jetzt aber gerade
daran in den vorbereitungen zu neuem
album neuer single bad überhaupt wenn
man das sieht einer der erfolgreichsten
newcomer 2012 goldstatus mit eurer
single echt habt ihr erreicht diverse
preise abgesahnt
und wie geht es jetzt weiter
oder wir machen jetzt erstmal pause und
den urlaub
drei jahre work and travel
also wir wir sind jetzt gerade dabei ist
wir haben jetzt die zweite platte schon
fertig wir waren in london und durften
da unsere zweite platte aufnehmen mit
einem wirklich wunderbaren produzenten
und es war für uns auch eine riesenehre
mit diesem mann zusammen zu arbeiten und
wer war das kind von den ja das war der
johann niveau heißt ja und der hat unter
anderem mit den pet shop boys
zusammengearbeitet mit den sugarbabes
und wir wir haben ja es war wirklich
total cool und die stadt war auch super
dass wir haben uns sehr gefreut waren da
vier wochen am stück dann wieder zwei
wochen da und er habe es sehr genossen
noch mit ihm zusammen zu arbeiten und
wir haben davor ja auch unser unsere
musik war es ihnen gezeigt diese demo
version unsere songs die wir geschrieben
haben und er hat sich da sehr begeistert
dafür sind gemein hätten wir auch gar
nicht gedacht haben es einfach mal so
kopiert ob er nicht vielleicht lust
hätte man mit uns zusammenzuarbeiten und
das war dann tatsächlich so und es war
eine wunderbare zusammenarbeit dass ich
hab dann auch immer so versucht ihm die
texte zu übersetzen weil es ihm auch
wichtig war zu wissen
ok um was geht es in dem sorgen dass wir
haben wirklich gut zusammengearbeitet
das alles harmoniert hat und jetzt haben
wir haben ein super album zusammen wie
ich finde
besonders toll war dass wir in den
vorberatungen also bei einem studio in
london haben dann quasi die zweite
platte gemacht dann haben wir uns die
meldung bekommen dass die erste gold
gegangen ist also das wirklich auch das
vor ein paar wochen dass die das album
auch noch gold gegangen
ich meine das kann man immer noch nicht
realisieren was eigentlich abgeht also
dass wir freuen uns einfach tierisch
dass es so viele menschen begeistert
dass wir uns da mal irgendwann im
proberaum ausdenken und ja es einfach
eine tolle zeit und genau
ja auf jeden fall die die neue platte
kommt mitte mai und singt ist schon in
den startlöchern also die wird mit dem
märz erscheinen und wir freuen uns mitte
april natürlich natürlich genau
wunderbar wie ist sowieso situationen
wenn man so ein erfolg gehabt hat hat
man dann angst dass man es nicht
fortschreiben kann
wie geht man anderen zweites album
angeht war da ganz entspannt ran und
denkt sich ist egal ob sitzriesen
erfolgreich wird oder keine ahnung
mittelmäßig läuft oder sagt man sich und
das muss jetzt ein erfolg werden wir
müssen einfach erfolgreicher werden
sonst haben wir keine gute geschichte zu
erzählen wie ist das geht einem da hat
man ein riesen bammel oder ist man ganz
entspannt
also sind da wir sind auch menschen
verlassen so was immer auf uns zukommen
also wir freuen uns tierisch weil wir
eigentlich sagen können wir stehen
eigentlich noch wie zu 100 prozent mehr
hinter der zweiten platte weil sie
einfach noch persönlicher ist und für
uns ist das was ganz besonderes und wenn
wir sie auch jetzt hören einfach so eine
letzten zügen bis jetzt alles fertig ist
hat man die chance auch im 70.000 mal
und wir können da wirklich sagen es ist
echt schön geworden und jetzt mal
schauen was passiert also wir wir machen
uns dann gedanken wenn es soweit ist
also wir sind auf jeden fall super happy
damit und ja wir hoffen unsere fans auch
seid ihr wirklich sicher dass sie gut
geworden ist weil man kann ja wer ich
weiß es beim abhören kann ja einfach
tierisch laut trainer und damit sich auf
nahezu alles gut an fast alles die
sicherheit seid ihr sicher dass es
wirklich gut geworden ist oder was habt
ihr für gefühl jetzt werdet ihr
natürlich okay wenn er ein schlechtes
gefühl abwendet jetzt lügen
nein nein also wirklich
ich muss wirklich sagen man hört sie
auch leise an ab und zu das das hört
sich also herzlich für mich und vor
allem das gefühl stimmt ich glaube es
ist wichtigste weil die texte die kamen
beim zweiten aber noch mehr von uns
selber und es sind geschichten die wir
selber erlebt haben und ja ich denke mal
dass es das wichtigste dass es vom
gefühl her einfach stimmt dass das
gefühl stimmt dass es wirklich die
aussagen sind zudem wir hundertprozentig
stehen und die wir so erlebt haben und
das merkt man glaube ich auch dass es
100 prozentig von uns kommt habt ihr
nicht angst da manchmal zu viel von euch
preiszugeben das ist so persönlich wird
ich denke das ist ja es ist manchmal so
ein bisschen schwierig also ich hab aber
ich habe ja auch überlegt bei einem song
get der wirklich sehr sehr persönlich
ist ja von mir kommt da hab ich mir auch
überlegt ob es vielleicht gleich
schwierig werden würde wie gehe ich
damit um auch in interviewsituationen
wie erzähle ich das ist natürlich immer
so eine frage die man sich selber stellt
aber ich denke dass das es mir gut getan
hat über über das thema zu sprechen oder
dass ich auch das bedürfnis hatte mir
das von der seele zu schreiben und
dass das vielleicht auch die fans sich
freuen würden oder sagen und ok die die
sich auch damit identifizieren können
mit dem thema und sagen ich habe
vielleicht das gleiche erlebt oder so
was ähnliches
und dass einem das auch kraft gibt und
das war ja auch meine intention zu sagen
ich möchte dass über mich schreiben weil
ich weiss es haben andere auch erlebt
und den gibt es vielleicht auch kraft
und mir selber gibt es ja auch kraft
deswegen habe ich es auch getan
welches thema ist es welche sorgen ist
es weil wir sind jetzt vor der
albumveröffentlichung fte noch nicht
die nagelprobe
ja ich hab da einfach wer das
geschrieben als über meinen vater
geschrieben was ich mir immer die klappe
und dann ja das ist für die geschichte
dahinter aber welche geschichte ist es
kannst du es jetzt schon sagen oder
einfach ja meine eltern haben sich
getrennt und ich habe zu meinem vater
nicht so guten kontakt und das war dann
einfach so was mir auf der seele lag und
darüber habe ich dann also ich habe
quasi auch ihnen angesprochenen dem song
und ich habe auch freundinnen die gesagt
haben das ist total super weil die haben
das dass ich den geschrieben hab eben
weil die haben das auch so selber erlebt
und das war dann einfach auch so ein
bisschen so für mich auch also es tut
einem gutes zu schreiben ist es ein
bisschen so wenn man sowas einer großen
menge menschen erzählt ist es etwa auch
eine befreiung ja ich bin ich bin mal
gespannt wie das sein wird einem konzert
das ich weiß jetzt ich weiß es jetzt
auch nicht also wenn ich jetzt auf
platte höher oder als im studio
eingesungen habe und da geschrieben habe
was natürlich schon ein stück weit eine
befreiung oder irgendwie schön dass man
auszusprechen so aber jetzt auch einen
konzerten weiß es noch nicht weiß schon
sehr persönlich ist und wenn ein land so
viele leute angucken
ich bin jetzt mal gespannt also wieder
so für ein gefühl wird oder was ist vom
gefühl wird du hast jetzt ein bisschen
erzählt das was du im song erzählt
meinst du könntest das auch jemand so
erzählen oder ist der song eine hilfe um
sowas loszuwerden
ja ich denke das ist immer so also für
mich den songs immer eine art irgendwas
zu erzählen was man glaube ich so
einfach nicht erzählen könnte also wenn
man mit der normalen sprache sag ich
jetzt mal ich denke über die musik kann
man sich auch besser ausdrücken es fällt
einem leichter und das war auch bei dem
song auf jeden fall so das ist ja auch
etwas das ist ja so ein stein den er
jetzt ins wasser schmeißt
in jeglicher beziehung hast du angst
davor was da passieren könnte ist es
eine spannung oder nee also ich denke
dass mit dem song alles gesagt wird und
man weiß natürlich nicht was was
passiert wenn wir die reaktion sein
werden aber ich habe jetzt keine angst
davor weil ich weiß ich stehe dazu dass
ich da singe und ja dann würde ich euch
wahnsinniger erfolg mit dem iphone das
hört sich alles sehr spannend und
interessant an und in jeglicher hinsicht
inhaltlich wie musikalisch
ich bin wirklich sehr gespannt das
könnte ja was werden